to provide a better experience we're
saying tourism we're local news crews
filming a breakfast feature on the
economy it was live and what happened
next was played out in front of
thousands of viewers while that was
going on a man walked up behind them
camera in one hand a gun in the other he
waits for a few moments watches and
pulls the trigger several times as the
camera hits the floor it captures this
haunting image of the gunman standing
over his victims
the program director cuts back to the
studio the presenter clearly shocked
shall we walk or let you know as soon as
we find out what those sounds were from
24-year old reporter Alison Parker and
her cameraman 27 year old Adam Ward were
shot dead both described as popular
members of a tight-knit TV station a
manhunt was launched by the Sheriff's
Office and Virginia State Police and it
wasn't long before a suspect was named
41 year old Vester Lee Flanagan was the
police said a former employee at the CBS
station on-air he called himself Bryce
Williams a police chase across Virginia
was launched as Williams fled up the
interstate highway at just after midday
authorities said they believed Williams
had shot himself during the chase the
suspect from this incident the shooting
died at Fairfax and Nova Hospital in
Northern Virginia as a result of a
self-inflicted gunshot wound many of you
have gotten a lot of the correspondence
emails that have been sent out it's
obvious that there was this gentleman
was disturbed in some way of the way
things had transpired at some point in
his life it would appear things were
spiraling out of control but we're still
looking into that Williams left a trail
of information on his social media
accounts he boasted that he had filmed
the shooting and posted it online a
chilling record of a horrific act he
claimed the two journalists had racially
abused him at work someone with a gun we
believe it was a man
barged into where they were and fired
several shots employees at the
television station took to the air with
the news paying tribute to their
colleagues on the same program which had
witnessed their killing just hours
before there were special people and you
know as Leo had said they would brighten
up a room every morning you know we're
all sleepy we're all you know tired but
they would come in it was like
gangbusters and Adam come in he grabbed
a piece candy go and say something to
Leo about the Bruins or the Red Sox or
something and talk about Virginia Tech
and you know Allison come in just kind
of bouncing just happy just to start her
day and you know today was just like any
other day the show's anchor Chris Hurst
revealed that he had been in a
nine-month relationship with Alison
Parker and they were planning to get
married he said he was numb with shock
Adam Ward's partner was reportedly in
the news gallery watching the program
when the shooting happened
the chilling events on breakfast news
have shocked America and once again the
age-old debate here about gun control
has been reopened Amanda Walker Sky News
Virginia